hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well as with the first
formulation of Kant's categorical
imperative when we look at the second
one which you can see here we'll talk
about that in just a second when you
look at this you want to have some
examples in order to understand how this
would actually play itself out how it
how it would be applied and fortunately
for us Kant provides us with four
examples in the course of discussing
this formulation of the the categorical
imperative and his running through these
is actually a bit more illuminating I
think than his running through the exact
same examples for the first formulation
there's a little bit more intuitive a
bit easier to grasp I think for the
average person the average student it
doesn't require you to try to go through
this this grand process of trying to
think of what what if the entire world
was like this and is there any logical
contradiction instead what we're looking
at is issues about ends and means how is
humanity being being treated in this and
just to review a little bit here's
here's how it runs act in such a way
that you always treat humanity whether
in your own person or in the person of
an another never simply as a means but
always at the same time
so what does that mean well you notice
that it has two parts it's saying that
you have to treat humanity in not only
other people but also in yourself so
you're a person they're people you have
human dignity they have human dignity
you're supposed to respect that human
dignity in each person including
yourself so that precludes certain
things where somebody could say well I'm
not hurting anybody
therefore everything I want to do is
okay count would say no there's some
things that are actually not okay even
though they're not actually hurting
another person because they're actually
detrimental to the humanity in yourself
the other thing that's important here is
the question of whether you're treating
a person has a means or as an end and I
need to clarify it again here it's
possible to treat a person both as a
means and as an end in the same action
or decision or policy particularly you
know if you're thinking about in terms
of a relationship something that's a
structured overtime that takes place in
a number of different steps or sequences
it becomes a a little bit trickier then
and we'll look at some examples in the
next video not in this one which deal
with that but we want to look at cots
own examples there's a few other things
that are that are important to bring out
one is he distinguishes between weight
equals merely subjective ends and
objective ends and what are merely
subjective ends well these are the ends
that we settle upon and which guide are
practical reasoning our decision-making
our choices but really have reference
only to our own desires and inclinations
they're not desires and inclinations
that are held by everybody for example
when I get up in the morning one of the
first things I do is I make myself some
coffee and you can ask yourself why does
he do that well that's a that's a matter
of subjective ends I want the alertness
that coffee brings to me I don't really
feel myself because I'm an addict
caffeine actually
I don't feel entirely with it until I
have my first cup of morning coffee
sometimes my second cup of morning
coffee depending on how strong it is and
I also like the taste of coffee
now does that apply to everybody no
that's a subjective and then I take for
my myself the coffee itself can be a
means to an end in terms of a larger
frame or two why do I need to be alert
and to taste something that tastes good
so I can concentrate on grading early in
the morning that would be grading would
be the end and drinking the coffee and
the alertness and and all that would be
merely a means now objective ends our
ends that every rational being as a
rational being can say yes that's
something that we want to aim for so for
example preservation of innocent life
that doesn't mean that everybody
actually says yes I want to preserve
innocent life I want to keep people safe
or anything like that but they ought to
as rational beings that ought to be
something that would be an end for their
their will so now let's look at what
trot says in some of these examples
start off by talking about necessary
duty or strict duty and again we have
strict duty of meritorious to be strict
duty towards oneself what would be an
example of that well whether one kills
oneself
he had that example of a person who
decides to shorten his life because his
life turns out to be unpleasant for him
and he says you know is it permissible
for me it's a short in my life so that I
don't have to endure or suffering I
don't have to endure pain I don't have
to endure things that I don't like you
know maybe humiliation discomfort you
know it doesn't necessarily have to be
physical suffering it could be could be
mental suffering as well loneliness for
example and he says
the man contemplates suicide we'll ask
can my action be compatible with the
idea of humanity as an end in itself
here we go an end all right so he says
if he doesn't weigh with himself in
order to escape from a painful situation
so there there's a goal right doing him
away with himself to escape from a
painful situation he's treating that as
an end getting away from the pain
how was he treating his humanity he's
treating his humanity as a mere means to
that end
he's using his very capacities of choice
reasoning things out of sort of you know
forecasting what the future is going to
be like being able to weigh alternatives
he's using all of that as a means to
alleviating pain or suffering or perhaps
even a loneliness or something along
those lines so he says he is making use
of a person what person himself merely
as a means to maintain a tolerable state
of affairs till the end of his life so
here's what Kant says that man is not a
thing not something to be used merely as
a means he must always in all his
actions be regarded as an end in himself
hence I cannot dispose of man or
humanity in my person by maiming
spoiling or killing so I would actually
say if we wanted to think about this
some people alleviate their their
anguish by engaging in in actions which
maim themselves Khan would actually be
against that self-mutilation now he also
says something here too and this is
maybe a little bit a cop out at this
point but I will do other videos later
on where he does explore these things he
says a more precise determination of
this principle in order to avoid all
misunderstandings for example about
having limbs amputated to save myself
let's say you know you actually get
gangrene is it permissible to chop off
your arm concept yeah of course but
there you're not treating yourself as a
mere means you're actually treating
yourself as a net
the explanation of that has a little bit
more complex and he doesn't he discusses
that in other work so I'm gonna put that
off for right now
what about exposing my life to danger in
order to preserve it
yes he's also willing to say that that
could be allowable as well okay so that
is strict duty to oneself and strict
duty for Kant has to do with whether
your action would conflict or not with
humanity whether it would treat humanity
as a means by conflicting with it by Sir
no you know negating it nullifying at
placing it in a lower context now he
says what about necessary or strict duty
to other people the person who he has in
mind making a false promise to others
you remember that was the the other
classic example we'll see it once that
he's intending to make use of another
person merely as a means to an end which
he meaning that other person does not
share so to respect another person as an
end means understanding that they not
only have subjective ends of their own
which may not map on to mind which
probably actually don't map on to mine
insofar as our ends our goals or desires
are merely subjective they're probably
not you know in complete alignment they
probably are not identical they may in
fact conflict with each other we can't
agree upon objective as that stuff that
we can all share as rational beings now
if I'm treating another person as a
means I am in a certain respect treating
them as a thing not respecting their
capacity to set ends for themselves so
the question here is can I make a false
promise to another person in order to
get something from them if I do that I'm
treating them merely as a means so he
says the man who might seek to use for
my purposes by such a promise cannot
possibly agree with my way of behaving
to him and so cannot himself share the
end
the action that's an interesting point
to make and we're going to come back to
that in a moment
but let's go on a little bit further
then we'll come back to that question
about the possibly so he says this
incompatibility with the principle of
duties to others leaps to the I more
obviously when we bring in other
examples what are other examples
attempts on the freedom to enslave
somebody for example perhaps even to
kidnap them you know would be another
example attempts on the freedom and the
property of others if I if I make an
attempt on the property of others what
are we talking about there robbery theft
fraud whole range of things counts as
these sort of actions when we engage in
them we're treating others as less than
what they are we're treating them as
things to be used as things that we get
what we want our ends our subjective
ends satisfied by them but we don't
respect their ends and we can't possibly
expect them to do that and if you think
about fraud for example if you're going
to defraud somebody you have to trick
them why because if they actually knew
what you were up to they wouldn't trust
you right now let's go back to the
possibly can you say this in every case
count doesn't go on to consider this but
what about say a masochist somebody who
enjoys being humiliated being threatened
being punished being injured that is
having somebody else impose their ends
upon them and treat them as a mere
object would that be what they call a
defeater for for cotton his moral theory
well I don't think so for two reasons
one approach that a consciente to that
would be to say well you know a person
like that just has different subjective
ends and what they're really about is
getting humiliated right or getting hurt
and so
you you know there's that old joke about
a masochist as a person who says hurt me
hurt me and a sadist as a person who
says no I won't because the sadness is
the one who wants to actually hurt the
other person and if like pain on them to
contravene their desires and the
masochist really wants to have their
desires contravene if that's the case
then that is their desire is sort of a
higher-order desire and that maybe
they're their ends could be in an
alignment I don't think that's a good
country answer I think there's something
wrong with taking that that sort of
approach to it I think a better
conscience your answer is to say well
look a person like that who's agreeing
to that who's agreeing to be used as a
mere means to it by another person is
screwed up in a certain way their their
whatever ends they're pursuing are
merely subjective ends they're not
objective rational ends that that you
know every rational being could in fact
share ratify recognize as being what
they want to do let's go on now so we've
looked at strict duty strict duty
shouldn't conflict with the humanity and
one's self and others meritorious Duty
is a little bit different
remember meritorious duties are the ones
where can't you know and this is what
meritorious duty means not just for
conquer for other people it's okay if
you don't do them it's not like you've
actually gone against duty you've been
immoral by not doing them but it's
better if you do them it's a good thing
for you to do it sort of like you don't
have to give to charity but it's a good
thing for you to do it you have a a less
strict duty to give to other people out
of your surplus if you see somebody
starving on the street then you do have
a duty to save them I would say right
maybe some people would disagree about
that but if you see somebody who is hard
up and there's other people who could
contribute and you you know you've got
money in your wallet and you say should
I do this there's there's a sense in
which you should but it's not the should
that compels that's what we
by meritorious and in that case one's
action want to harmonize he says with
humanity so let's look at what he says
here in regard to contingent or
meritorious duty to oneself we do have
duties to ourselves and it's interesting
here because con you know says we not
only have meritorious duties to other
people we have meritorious duties to
ourselves we don't just have strict
duties to ourself like don't get
yourself killed
we also have meritorious duties to
herself like like what well should I
develop my talents capacities my
intellect my moral sensibilities my
memory should I develop these these
aspects of myself should I engage in the
process of Education whether
intellectual or moral or perhaps even
you know in terms of trades or things
like that he says there aren't humanity
capacities for greater perfection every
single one of us can make progress and
when we do that we are gaining we're
getting greater perfection as Khan says
it it's easy to get tripped up here
because we tend to think of perfection
is like being the acne the one top point
right you are in ten out of ten
well perfection is also a relative term
we can say that some things are more
perfect than than others you know if we
talk about a perfect cup of coffee
that's probably a very relative term not
just relative in the sense of its
relative to the person drinking the
coffee in this case me this is not a
perfect cup of coffee by the way but
relative to what it is that makes coffee
coffee or makes a coffee drink a coffee
drink for instance I would like a little
bit more robustness to this we actually
bought Dunkin Donuts coffee to fill in a
gap when we normally buy very dark roast
I'm kind of a dark roast guy I would
like a little bit more body to it that
would make it more perfect now human
beings are like this too we can make
progress and we can attain higher and
higher
of perfection thereby so you know for
instance as you're learning contrite you
are perfecting your mind you're not by
the time you're done with Conte you're
not absolutely perfect you're not at the
act me that you need the highest
point.but you've you've made some some
progress here you're you have more to
contribute you have more to put on the
table you have more to deploy on your
part than you did when you first walked
in the door and never heard about [ __ ]
right so he says there are humanity
capacities for greater perfection which
form part of nature's purpose for
Humanity in our person this might be a
big leap on some of people's party you
can't he has a teleological
understanding of nature nature he has
intended us to to be in certain ways or
to develop in certain ways and there's I
have another video about this where are
we talking about you know why did we get
reason was it for happiness or was it
for something greater than happiness you
can you can take a look at that top
clearly thinks that we were given these
potentialities so that we could in fact
actualize them and that requires work
and choice and determinations on our
part and commitment that we have to make
over and over and over again so he says
to neglect these can be compatible with
the maintenance of humanity as an end in
itself so if you neglect these if you
say I'm just gonna watch beer and play
xbox and listen to music and go out and
get on the dole and you know pick
whatever you want right an easy
lifestyle where you don't actually have
to develop yourself as a person
intellectually morally maybe even
physically that is not incompatible per
se with the humanity within oneself but
it doesn't harmonize with it he says
it's compatible with the maintenance of
humanity has intended itself but not
with the promotion of this end in order
to really treat a person oneself as
having full dignity worth you have to
actually care about your own development
compensate that's a very interesting
thought there's a lot of implications to
that well let's go on meritorious duties
to other people
he said the natural end which all people
seek is is what happiness happiness is
the satisfaction of our desires and
inclinations the pursuit and attaining
of our merely subjective ends because
happiness is different for each one of
us according to Kant he says humanity
could no doubt subsist if everyone
contributed nothing to the happiness of
others but at the same time refrain from
deliberately impairing their happiness
so everybody obeys a set of rules nobody
steals nobody you know de frauds anybody
else nobody kills anybody for no good
reason
you know we obey about your rule but we
say screw you as far as everything else
I've got mine you've got yours and we're
not going to help each other out I'm not
gonna help you right
that would be what he's talking about
here so humanity could exist and there's
nothing you know transgressing against
somebody's humanity like there is when
you go out and you you you Club them
over the hat right there you're
definitely treating that person as a
mere means to whatever end it is that
you're trying to attain by clubbing them
over the head or we need to fraud them
or when you you cheat you know or thing
you you take a bribe and and find them
guilty or find them innocent or things
like that but he says this is however to
merely to agree negatively and not
positively with humanity as an end in
itself unless everyone endeavors also so
far as within him lies he's not saying
you have to like you know give
everything but so far as lives within
your power to further the ends of
and now notice these are not just
objective ends these are subjective us
if you can make somebody's day brighter
and it's not gonna actually cost you too
much it's not gonna you know radically
derail your own progress or whatever
ends you're pursuing cut let's say you
well you ought to do that it's not you
know you're not a bad person if you
don't do that but you're certainly not a
good person if you want to be a good
person you actually have to fulfill
meritorious duties as well to be a good
person in that sense means really
engaging the humanity of other people
and engaging the humanity of one's self
not just respecting it by you know not
transgressing against it but promoting
it trying to make things better so he
says the the ends of a subject who has
an aunt who is an end in himself must if
this conceptionist have its full effect
in me if I'm really to be a moral being
be also as far as possible - so you know
if I if I'm not into a particular genre
of music but somebody else is and I can
get them not only some CDs of that music
but also put them in touch with somebody
who's you know really good at producing
that kind of music and I know that that
would make them happy at least in that
respect that would satisfy some of their
ads I can make those my own ads even
though I don't have an active desire
myself for that and I would say well if
I if that were me I wouldn't really get
anything out of that as a matter of fact
I might see it as a waste of time I can
grasp because of grasping the humanity
and another person I can grasp that
that's their ends and I can make those
in in a way through practical choices
and actions I can make those my own ends
now there is one other example that Kant
doesn't talk about in this section but
it is an example that he talked about
earlier in the groundwork and so it's
one that I want
bring up and I want to close with this
one because this is a really good
example so he talks about the shopkeeper
who gives fair prices this ties in
really well with business ethics right
because one of the things that you see
coming up over and over again in
business ethics both in business ethics
courses in the sort of broader community
is you should be ethical because it's
good for business
you should do the right thing and not
break the rules and don't cheat people
and give people fair prices because
you'll get some sort of payoff for that
there's something that's left out there
right why should you be ethical because
it's the right thing to do not just
because it will you know bring happiness
to the greatest number not just because
it will produce you know profits for the
stockholders not just because it will
make you will feel warm and fuzzy inside
but for Kant because it's the right
thing to do and you recognize it is the
right thing to do so giving customers a
fair price if I'm giving them a fair
price only because I want them to keep
buying from me so I'm being ethical I'm
being an ethical business person but
only because I want to preserve the
contact that I have I'm not really
treating the that person as an end in
themselves I'm not fully treating them
as an end I'm treating them more as a
means and I'm treating my own action and
I'm treating myself in a certain way as
a mere means to making more and more
money or to assuring a constant cash
flow Kant would disapprove of that Khan
would say if you're going to give people
a fair price you want to be giving them
a fair price because that's what they
actually deserve to recognize and to
treat humanity as an end in other people
would entail giving them a fair price
and not just because it's going to be
good for business not just so you can
stay out of jail not just because it
makes you feel warm and fuzzy inside not
just because you happen to love these
custom
but because it's the right thing to do
so I think that's a good example too
close with